hello and welcome back this week the
first thing we'll do is show you a
number of case studies of effective
convolutional neural networks so why not
a case studies last week you learn about
the basic building blocks such as
convolutional layers proving layers and
fully connected layers of cornets it
turns out a lot of the past few years of
computer vision research has been on how
to put together these basic building
blocks to form effective convolutional
neural networks and one of the best ways
for you to gain intuition yourself is to
see some of these examples I think just
as many of you might have learned to
write code by reading other people's
code I think that a good way to gain
intuition how to build confidence is
read or to see other examples of
effective confidence and it turns out
that a net neural network architecture
that works well on one computer vision
tasks often works well on other tasks as
well such as maybe on your toes so if
someone else is trained in your network
has always figured out in your network
architecture there's very good at
recognizing cats and dogs and people but
you have a different computer vision
task that maybe you're trying to build a
self-driving car you might well be able
to take someone else's new network
architecture and apply that to your
problem and finally after the next few
videos you'll be able to read some of
the research papers from the field of
computer vision and I hope that you
might find it satisfying as well you
don't have to do this to this class but
hope you might find it satisfying simply
read you know some of these seminal
computer vision research paper and see
yourself able to understand them so that
let's get started as an outline for what
we'll do in the next few videos we'll
first show you a few classic networks
the Linette 5 network which came from
you guess the 1980s alex net which is
often cited in the vgg Network and these
are examples of pretty effective neural
networks and some of the ideas laid the
foundation for modern computer vision
you see ideas in these papers that are
probably useful for your own and you see
ideas from these papers that will
probably be useful for your own work as
well
then one to show you the resident or
call residual network and you might have
heard that new networks are getting
deeper and deeper the rest net new
network trained a very very deep hundred
and fifty-two layer in your network then
has some very interesting tricks
interesting ideas how to do that
effectively and then finally you also
see a case study of the inception neural
network after seeing these neural
networks I think you have much better
intuition about how to build effective
convolutional neural networks and even
if you end up not working computer
vision yourself I mean you find that a
lot of the ideas from some of these
examples such as residency inception
Network many of these ideas that cross
fertilizing are making their way into
other disciplines so even if you don't
end up building computer vision
applications yourself I think you found
some of these ideas very interesting and
helpful for your work